SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
COME TO ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I WILL BE MAKING
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED. TO CONTINUE
OUR ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. SO LET ME COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT%
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE HAVE A PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND AN ACCESS
CODE IT IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL DO
BE DISPLAYED A COUPLE OF TIMES
ON OUR SCREEN AND INCLUDING
RIGHT NOW. SO TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO
FIVE NINE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING A IS CUSTOMARY AND
INDEED INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR COURT REPORTER I WOULD ASK
THAT ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES IN
WITNESSES ALIKE. AND HERE'S THE
KEY SPEAK SLOWLY. AND CLEARLY
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IN THE
TRANSMISSION IT BECOMES HARD
FOR OUR COURT REPORTER TO HEAR
SO I MAY HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
SLOW DOWN- ARE REPEAT YOURSELF
AND TRULY IT IS ONLY SO THAT WE
CAPTURE YOU FOR THE RECORD. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM OUT LET
ME I'M JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT-
SENATOR GROVE IS NOT PRESENT
TODAY AND SENATOR BATES WILL BE
SOMEWHAT LATE- SHE IS.
CONDUCTING OTHER LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BUT SHE WILL BE HERE
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC KNOW THAT
SO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR HER TO ADD ON TO ANY ITEMS
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN. SO A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME THAT WE VOTE. SO
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROOF
KAMLAGER HERE I'M LONGER HERE
LETTER HERE LEHRER HERE K.
BATES ATKINS HERE I CAN SEE
HERE. THANK YOU I AM GONNA GO
AHEAD BEFORE WE ARE- IF THERE
ARE NO OBJECTIONS I WANT TO
TAKE UP FIRST ON THE AGENDA
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND THAT'S
ITEMS TO D. THROUGH G. AND JUST
FOR THE RECORD. D. IS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION I HE IS THE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES-
AND F. ALSO BOARDED BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AND SHE IS COMMISSION
ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND I
UNDERSTAND I DO NOT NEED TO
SEPARATE THOSE VOTES OUT. ARE
CONFIRMING THAT- OKAY WITH THAT
I WILL TAKE MOTION I WOULD MOVE
ITEMS TO D. THROUGH TWO G.
THANK YOU SENATOR MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH KAMLAGER I AM LONGER I'D
FLARED HI I FAITH ATKINS I CAN
SIGN ON CALL ON CALL- THANK YOU
I WOULD LOVE TO TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER. THREE REFERENCE OF
BILLS TO COMMITTEES. I ACTUALLY
MET MADAM- SENATOR I THINK I
COULD TAKE UP ITEM THREE AND
FOUR TOGETHER IF I SEE NO-
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT OKAY. WOULD
YOU MAKE THAT MOTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR COM LAGER MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
PROVE KAMLAGER HI NO LONGER I'D
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES.
ATKINS I HAVE CONCERNS AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL AS WELL
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES SO NOW WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND TURN TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR ITEM ONE A. THE
APPOINTMENT OF MISS LILIANA M.
BAILEY CRIMMINS. AS CHIEF OF
THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY
SERVICES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SO CHIEF BAILEY
CRIMMINS LET ME WELCOME YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS
WE GOT UNDER WAY I WANT TO ASK
YOU IF YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR THANK
AND THEN OPENING COMMENTS IF
YOU WOULD LIKE AND THEN WE'LL
GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS OF THE-
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. OKAY SIR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIANNA
BAILEY CRIMMINS CHIEF OF THE
OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY AND THE
STATE CHIEF TECHNOLOGY OFFICER.
WITH M TODAY IS MY WONDERFUL
HUSBAND ART CRIMMINS WITH
AMERICA FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
AND OUR SON WHO IS- WE ARE
EXTREMELY PRODUCT HE IS SERVING
HIS COUNTRY AS AN OFFICER IN
THE AIR FORCE AND BOTH ARE
SUPPORTING ME VIRTUALLY TODAY.
FOR MY OPENING STATEMENT I WANT
TO THANK GOVERNOR NYESOM. AND
IN THE TOP OF THE STATE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
OPPORTUNIT TO IMPROVE THE
DIGITAL LICENSE CALIFORNIANS.
BY PUTTING PEOPLE FIRST WHEN WE
DEPLOY TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS. I
ALSO WANT TO PERSONALLY THANK
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE STAFF FOR THEIR
SYSTEMS DURING HIS CONFIRMATION
PROCESS. I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
WHY I A SOUGHT OUT THIS
PARTICULAR POSITION SO I WAS
THE CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF
TECHNOLOGY. IT IS A ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY TO GET
BACK TO AN I. T. COMMUNITY THAT
I HAVE BEEN SERVING ALONG SIDE
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS. I'M IN
THOSE THIRTY YEARS I HAVE
SERVED IN EIGHT INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS AND HAVE FOCUSED ON
MODERNIZING THEIR TECHNOLOGY
MISSIONS. AND IN THIS- OPPOSITE
THIS ROLE I'LL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE OF KNOWLEDGE
AND SKILLS TO SERVE THREE
HUNDRED PLUS ANY LOCAL AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS. MY HIGHEST
PRIORITY IS TO FOCUS ON THE
GOALS AND THE CHALLENGES LAID
OUT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES VISION TWENTY
TWENTY THREE STRATEGIC PLAN. BY
DELIVERING SECURE OPTIMIZED
DEPENDABLE TECHNOLOGY SERVICES
TO THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF LEADING
A GROUP LED TEAM OF TECHNOLOGY
EXPERTS WHERE OUR PURPOSE IS TO
BE A TRUSTED ADVISER AS
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC SERVICE
DEPARTMENTS WANT TO ADVANCE AND
SECURE THEIR TECHNOLOGIES AND
SERVE THEIR CONSTITUENTS. I AM
COMMITTED TO DELIVERING
INNOVATION WITH PURPOSE. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IN THE END THE
DAY WE UNDERSTAND THAT WE USED
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THE CITIZENS
AND THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE DO THAT FOR
PEOPLE PROCESS AND TECHNOLOGY.
READERS ARE ONLY AS SUCCESSFUL
AS A TEAM THAT THEY LAID.
ACROSS THE STATE SHOULD BE SET
UP IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY
PROMOTES INNOVATION. AND NOT
INHABITANTS. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO BUILDING BRIDGES ACROSS THE
I. T. COMMUNITIES BY
COMMUNICATION COLLABORATION AND
CONNECTION. AS WE LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO- SHARE LOOK
FOR SHARED SERVICES INNOVATIONS
AND BUILD UP RIGHT. AND DIGITAL
FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THAT CONCLUDES
MY OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND WITH THAT SENATOR
LAYERED I WILL START WITH YOU
ON DISAPPOINTING. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATED THE CHANCE TO- MEET
WITH THE APPOINTEE I THINK SHE
ANSWERED ALL MY QUESTIONS AND-
DEMONSTRATED- A GOOD LEVEL OF
COMPETENCE I'M GOING TO BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT FOR. I JUST
MAYBE ONE ONE QUESTION ABOUT
SOMETHING WE TALKED ABOUT AND
THAT WAS JUST- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE STATE HAD
DIFFICULTIES WITH VERY LARGE
PROJECTS THAT- YOU KNOW I HAVE
TROUBLE BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
THEN HAVE TO BE IMPLEMENTED
ACROSS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS. THAT ARE LOCATED
IN DIFFERENT PLACES AND WHERE
PEOPLE EVEN HAVE DIFFERENT.
LEVELS OF SKILL FOR NEEDS AND-
ARE YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE IN OUR TALK WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT HERE THE CHALLENGES
IN BATON AND HOW YOU WOULD
PROPOSE JUST AS PART OF YOUR
JOB TO MEET THEM. RIGHT OKAY
SENATOR LEAHY- SO ONE OF THINGS
I BELIEVE IT IS OPTIMIZING
PROCESSES BEFORE AUTOMATING
PROCESSES- AND MANY TIMES WHEN
WE HAVE CHALLENGES IT'S LOOKING
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS THE- IS THE
IS THE SILVER BULLET THAT'S
GOING TO SOLVE ALL THE BUSINESS
PROBLEM SO I FIRST LOOK AT WHEN
WE'RE DEPLOYING CHANGE AN
ORGANIZATION OR LOOKING AT
LARGE PROJECTS- MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
KNOWLEDGE AN ORGANIZATION TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT SO A LOT OF
TIMES IT'S PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS. MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE BROUGHT RIGHTS
BUSINESS SPONSORSHIP AND THAT
WE'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT THE
FUTURE OF WHERE OUR PROCESS
NEEDS TO BE ON BEHALF OF THE
RESIDENTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE AUTOMATING
AND THAT WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY
SOMETIMES WE HAVE THE DESIRED
CHANGE BUT WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
CAPABILITY THATWE'RE WILLING
TO DO THE HARD WORK NECESSARY-
AND- ALSO LOOKING AT CHANGE AND
INCREMENTAL I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO DELIVER
INCREMENTAL WINS VERSUS STATE
BANK- AND TECHNOLOGY FOR A LONG
TIME. WAITING FIVE YEARS FOR
FUNCTIONALITY IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT ANY OF US HAVE PATIENTS TO
DO AND WE BELIEVE THAT BY
PUTTING THESE THINGS AND
MODULES THAT WE ARE DELIVERING
GOOD FUNCTIONALITY TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND TO OUR
BUSINESS PARTNERS IT SHOWS- YOU
KNOW THAT WE'RE BUILDING UPON
OUR SUCCESSES AND I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO DO THAT
I THINK IT'S ALSO AS I WAS
TALKING ABOUT INNOVATION WITH
PURPOSE IS EXTREMELY. IMPORTANT
THAT WE DON'T FORGET WHO WE
SERVE- WHEN I WAS A
CORRECTIONAL HEALTHCARE WE WERE
MAKING SURE THAT- WHEN I CAME
TO THE NURSES THE DOCTORS
ALLIED HEALTH SERVICES IT'S A
PART OF MAKING SURE THAT WHEN
WE'RE DELIVERING INNOVATION
THAT IS IMPROVING THEIR ABILITY
TO DELIVER SERVICES- TO- THIS
CASE IT WAS IN MY PATIENTS AND
AS WE TALKED CENTER LAYERED I
BELIEVE WALKING A MILE IN OUR
CUSTOMERS SHOES IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AS WELL AS SOMETIMES
AGAIN NOT JUST FOCUSING ON THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT ACTUALLY
WALKING. OUT INTO- I WALKED
EVERY SINGLE INSTANCE. I ALSO
GO KIND OF LIKE SETTING UP A
DAY THE LIFE YOU ARE SO SIDE BY
SIDE WITH PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO. IMPLEMENTED INSURANCE.
HOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY UTILIZING-
PROCESSES SO THAT YOU'RE
AUTOMATING ALIGNED TO WHAT THEY
NEED. ONE OF THE THINGS I
NOTICED WHEN I WALKED OUT INTO
AN INSTITUTION WE HAD RECENTLY
CONVERTED ALL THE DIGITAL BEAT
THE FILM IMAGES TO. ADDITIONAL
AND WHEN I WALKED THE
INSTITUTION I SAW DENNIS
ACTUALLY DRILLING ANI- AN
INMATE PATIENTS TO. AND HE KEPT
WIGGLING THE MOUSE WITH HIS-
HIS FOOT AND- OBVIOUSLY NEED AN
OUTSIDER COULD QUITE UNDERSTAND
WHY THIS WE'RE GOING AMOUNTS
WITH THIS BUT- LET HIM FINISH
HIS JOB AFTER WAS DONE WE WENT
IN TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
HIM. AND HE SAID THAT WE HAD TO
FIND A POLICY THAT IF YOU
DIDN'T ACTUALLY MOVE THE MOUSE
OF THIS COMING MINUTES. HE
COULD ACTUALLY SEE THE SCREEN A
WORD THAT HE NEEDED TO DROUGHT.
AND SO- WE HAD UNBEKNOWNST TO
US TO FIND A POLICY THAT
ACTUALLY AFFECTED HIS ABILITY
TO DO ITS JOB. AND HE MAY NEVER
HAVE BROUGHT THAT UP AND SO I
JUST THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
DELIVER INCREMENTAL WINS THAT
WE NEVER FORGET- THAT WE NEED
TO GO OUT AND SEE HOW THAT
TECHNOLOGY. IS BEING APPLIED IN
REAL LIFE. AND YOU KNOW YOU
MEANT THAT. WHEN I MET WITH AND
I MEANT TO GET NAME OF THAT
DENTAL. TO MAKE SURE THAT I
DON'T TO. END UP THERE- THANK
YOU. THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO WORLD VOTED FOR
YOU THANKS MANAGER. THANK YOU
ALTHOUGH I MIGHT ADD THAT
DENNIS OBVIOUSLY KNEW HOW TO
GET HIS JOB DONE DESPITE THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK- I DIDN'T
CATCH THE STORED FIRST I
THOUGHT HE WAS WE'RE GOING TO.
OKAY BUT THAT IS A VERY GOOD
IT'S A VERY GOOD EXAMPLE I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL END USERS
WHO HAVE TO IT AT ANY RATE
SENATOR COME LONGER LET ME GO
TO YOU. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IT IS A PLEASURE AT CAN MEET
YOU AT MISS BAILEY CUMMINS I'M-
APOLOGIZE FOR US NOT. BEING
ABLE TO FIND TIME ADD TO ME BUT
I READ THROUGH YOUR BIO IN YOUR
RESPONSES AND THINK YOU ARE-
INCREDIBLY QUALIFIED. FOR THIS
JOB- I FEEL LIKE I SAY THIS A
LOT DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'D WANT
IT IT SEEMS OVERWHELMING- I
JUST I ALSO HAVE ONLY ONE
QUESTION- YOU KNOW I HAVE HEARD
THAT SOME DEPARTMENTS ARE STILL
USING COBALT- WHICH I THINK. I
LEARNED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT-
WHEN I WAS IN GRADUATE SCHOOL-
IN. THE PRIOR MILLENNIA AND SO.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
JUST SHARE WITH US HOW. YOU
KNOW HOW ANTIQUATED OR OUR OUR
SYSTEMS ARE SOFTWARE AND
HARDWARE SYSTEMS. AT ANTIQUATED
WHAT IS THE SORT OF THE
MODERNIZATION ROLL OUT- FOR
BOTH THE PLATFORMS. THAT WE ARE
A USING AND THAT ALSO- THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA CUSTOMERS- ARE
REALLY DEPENDENT UPON AND CAN
YOU JUST SHARE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW THAT'S- HOW THAT IS
GOING TO WORK BECAUSE WE HAVE
SO MANY DEPARTMENTS YOU HAVE SO
MANY DEPARTMENTS. THAT YOU HAVE
TO MONITOR- AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- SO WHEN
COBALT WAS- IMPLEMENTED THE
NICE THING ABOUT IT IS THAT WAS
HARDWARE AGNOSTIC RIGHT SO IT
WAS IT DID TRANSACTIONS
EXTREMELY WELL BETTER THAN ANY
OTHER TECHNOLOGY AND WAS AT- AT
AT THAT HAS THE BEST TIME THE
BEST THE BEST- CUTTING TO
LANGUAGE YOU COULD USE. AND SO
WE DO WE HAVE FOURTEEN
DEPARTMENTS THAT STILL USE
COBALT- THE SYSTEMS ARE
PERFORMING EXACTLY THE WAY THEY
WORK AND THE TRANSACTIONS ARE
PERFORMING AT A VERY HIGH
SPEED- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE PROBABLY
AWARE OF THIS THANKS 95% OF OUR
ATM TRANSACTIONS ARE STILL.
USED ON USING COBALT- AND 45%
OF THE BANKS FOR THEIR NEED A
PRIMARY SYSTEMS NEWS COBALT-
WHAT I LOOK FOR IS IT MEETING
THE NEEDS OF HER CONSTITUENTS-
I THINK T'S NOT THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT I WORRY SO MUCH ABOUT IT'S
THAT WE HAVE THIS HUGE. YOUR
PEOPLE ARE RETIRING- OR THEY'RE
NOT AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THE SYSTEMS AND SO OUR
JOB. YOU HAVE SEVERAL CHOICES
AS A DEPARTMENT AND MANY OF
THESE ARE THIRTY FORTY YEARS
OLD AND IT REQUIRES RE CODING-
IN YOUR BUILDING SOMETHING FROM
THE GROUND UP I. AT DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY WHAT I LIKE SO MUCH
IS THAT WE HAVE THE LATEST IBM
TECHNOLOGIES AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP DEPARTMENTS
MODERNIZE THEIR APPLICATIONS
THAT OCCURRED WITHIN THEIR
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT- WE DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT TILL YOU KNOW A
BIG BANG WHERE IT HAS TO GO
COMPLETELY INTO THE CLOUD SO I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY
INCREMENTAL WINS. ON THAT WE
CAN BE PUTTING AND PLACE AND
NOT NOT WAIT FOR EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE APPLICATIONS TO BE
REGRETFUL- I THINK THAT WOULD
BE A VERY LONG TIME AND IF WE
APPROACH IT THAT WAY- I THINK
IT WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US AS A STATE TO GET ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE WE HAVE TO LOOK FOR
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES. TO PULL
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THE
REPORTING PART OF IT IF IT'S A
CERTAIN PART OF THE APPLICATION
THAT RUNS- PARTS OF THE DATA
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES TO BREAK
THAT UP AND TO PROVIDE A LOW
CODE- SOLUTIONS TO THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT I HAVE TO SAY AND I.
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO OFFEND
YOU BUT- AS I WAS LISTENING TO
YOU I WAS THINKING IT IS SO
GREAT. THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPOINT A ONE
MAN. TO RUN ALL OF THIS-
BECAUSE SO OFTEN WHEN WE'RE
HAVING FOLKS TALK TO US ABOUT
I. T. WE'RE TALKING TO MEN. SO
AND I WE WERE JUST ACTUALLY ON
WOMEN'S CAUCUS CALL EARLIER
TODAY TALKING ABOUTWOMEN IN
TECH SO. YOU JUST AFFIRMED- THE
PROGRESS THAT I THINK WE'RE
MAKING SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE. OKAY THANK YOU A
SENATOR I ACTUALLY HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ONE. YOU KNOW I
REALLY APPRECIATED YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS WERE YOU TALK ABOUT
YOU'RE GOING TO GO FOR THE
INCREMENTAL WIN VERSUS THE BIG.
YOU KNOW BANG OR WHATEVER THE
PHRASEOLOGY YOU USED BECAUSE I
THINK. YOU KNOW THIS IS THE
STUFF IS COMPLEX AND IF YOU
DON'T TAKE THE TIME TO DO IT
AND MAKE SURE IT'S SOLID YOU
KNOW- YOU PAY THE PRICE DOWN
THE ROAD IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE A BIG SPLASH WHEN REALLY
WE SHOULD BE. FOCUSED ON THE
FOUNDATIONAL. WITH THAT IN MIND
I JUST WANT TO GET SOME OF YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO OF COURSE OUR- OUR SENATE
AND OUR WILL THE LEGISLATURE
WILL BE VOTING ON SOME ITEMS
TOMORROW. AND AS IT RELATES TO
BROADBAND. YOU KNOW WE ARE ON A
TIMELINE BASED ON. RESOURCES
WERE GETTING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT'S OUTLINED
THERE. I JUST LOVE YOUR
THOUGHTS A LITTLE BIT ON HOW
YOU'RE GONNA BE AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THAT OBVIOUSLY. HOW YOU
WHAT'S YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
AS WE- GET READY TO EXPAND.
INTO UNDERSERVED AREAS AND DO
IT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT
KIND OF MEETING THAT- THAT
POINT THAT YOU MADE ABOUT LET'S
DO IT RIGHT LET'S MAKE SURE
THOUGHT JUST THOUGHTS GENERAL
THERE'S NO. SPECIFIC QUESTION
THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS AN
EXCITING TIME- OBVIOUSLY THE
PANDEMIC HAD. HIGHLIGHTED THAT
WE KNEW THAT THE DIGITAL VITAL.
WAS VERY PRESENT IN OUR LIVES.
BUT WHEN EVERYONE WAS THEN-
REQUIRED TO STAY HOME AND
REALLY RELIED ON TECHNOLOGY
INTERNET. IT WAS EVEN MORE-
GLARING AND IT IS JUST A
WONDERFUL EXCITING TIME TO BE-
PARTS DEPARTMENT A PART OF
CALIFORNIA TO HELP. ADDRESS
THOSE THOSE UNDERSERVED AND
UNSERVED- IN THE COMMUNITIES
AND SO. JUST FOR- YOURSELF AND
FOR THE AUDIENCE- WHEN I WORKED
AT CORRECTIONAL HEALTHCARE-
THOSE PRISON SYSTEMS ARE ALMOST
LIKE CITIES FROM. AMONG
THEMSELVES AND WE NEED TO MOVE-
A LARGE IMAGES FROM ONE
INSTITUTION TO ANOTHER- THE
BROADBAND THAT WE HAD A FIBER
WE HAD BETWEEN THE INSTITUTIONS
FROM CRESCENT CITY ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO BLANK NEAR. THE MEXICO
BORDER- WAS NOT SUFFICIENT AND
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
COME TO THE TABLE WITH AS I HAD
LAID. DARK FIBER AND WORK I
STOOD UP THE ROLE HEALTH
PROGRAM- THAT ENABLE THAT
ACROSS ACROSS THE STATE- IN
ADDITION- YES SOME OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED MICROLITER ACRES- I
WORKED ON THE DARK FIBER. TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THAT AT ANY
POINT IN TIME THE DOCTORS HAVE
ACCESS TO MEDICAL RECORDS TO
PRESCRIPTION. THINGS ARE
NECESSARY SO I COME WITH THAT
KNOWLEDGE AND I GET TO PARTNER
WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR POINT
TEAM- THAT'S OVER AT THE FRONT
OFFICE OF BROADBAND AND DIGITAL
LITERACY. WE ARE OBVIOUSLY
WORKING AND WE CAN'T DO IT OUR
ORDER BUYER SOMETHING WE GET TO
ALSO WORK WITH THAT. CPU ST- A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR AND
ALSO- DEPARTMENT OF.
TRANSPORTATION THAT WE ALL
HAVE. GREAT SKILLS AS ONE THING
THAT. TRANSPORTATION HOUSES
THEY KNOW HOW TO BUILD RIGHT
AWAY AS THEY KNOW HOW TO LAY
FIBER- SO LEVERAGING OUR SKILL
SETS WE ARE. TECHNOLOGISTS WE
KNOW HOW TO BUILD BROADBAND
NETWORKS. THIRD PARTY MINISTERS.
OTHERS MANY OF THEM OUT THERE
WE HAVE YES EVERYONE LINE BUT
ONE THAT HELP BEEN VERY. IN THE
EDUCATE REALM AND IF YOU SEE
HAS DONE IT AND- JOB AND KNOWS.
WHAT WE TO APPLY. THAT IN SOME
SERVICE. SO IT'S GOING TO BE A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE SENATE- LOWS
COMMITTEE AND ADMINISTRATION.
YOUR SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO- ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT GAP. IN AND OUR- IT
IS A SOLID DIGITAL BIASES SIDE
SOCIETAL DECLINE I THINK WHICH
IS TIME THAT WE ADDRESS IT HEAD
ON. THANK YOU FOR THAT I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE IT AND- I KNOW
THAT MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ARE GOING TO REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO UPDATES ALONG THE
WAY- IN TERMS OF HOW THIS IS
GOING THE BIGGEST INVESTMENT.
EVER AND- IT MEANS SO MUCH TO
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT. I ONLY HAVE ONE LAST
QUESTION I WANTED TO MAYBE COME
IN A LITTLE BIT I HAVE THOUGHT.
A COUPLE OF COLLEGE COLLEAGUES
TO ASK FOR UPDATES AS PART OF
THE SOME OF OUR CAUCUS- OF
MEETINGS AND SO THAT WILL BE
COMING YOUR WAY AS- WELL AS-
YES BUT- CYBER SECURITY AND
YOUR THOUGHTS AROUND. I IN FACT
I THINK WE RECENTLY ASK ABOUT
THAT WE HAD A POINT TO USED TO
THE- CAL I SO BORED AND OTHERS
AND WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT CYBER
SECURITY YOUR THOUGHTS JUST
FROM. THE ROLE THAT YOU HAVE ON
CYBER SECURITY AND- MAYBE IT.
TOSS IN THERE A LITTLE BIT AS
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS PANDEMIC
AND DONE WROTE REMOTE OUT WORK.
AND MAY END UP WITH A HYBRID-
WITH SOME OF OUR STATE
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS OUR OWN.
OUR THOUGHTS ON CYBER SECURITY
JUST GENERALLY IN AND AS IT
RELATES TO. HOW WE'RE MOVING TO
WORK DIFFERENTLY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- PARTS MY CURRENT
ROLE I WAS OTHER CALPERS CHIEF
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER
WHICH INCLUDED- BEING A
PRIVACY. OFFICER AND SO I IT I
WORKED WITH THE FLORIDA AS A
FIDUCIARY DUTY REGARDING CYBER
AND- DID A LOT TO IMPROVE THEIR
SECURITY POSTURE THERE SO
THAT'S- THAT'S THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT I BRING TO THIS ROLE. I
GET TO PARTNER WITH- THE CHIEF
INFORMATION SECURITY OFFICER.
AND WHAT I BELIEVE IS I MEAN
AGAIN IT'S ALL EXCEPT
CYBERSECURITY IS ALL OUR
RESPONSIBILITY- IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE ESPECIALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC ONE OF THE THINGS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE. ALL THE
SECURITY SAFEGUARDS AND WE
HAVE. AN ON PREMISE IN
BUILDING- ENVIRONMENT IS WHAT
WAS APPLIED ACROSS THE STATE
AND SO- THE INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICER MAKE SURE THAT
THERE WAS- INFORMATION SHARED
OUT TO ALL THE DEPARTMENTS. AND
AGAIN WHEN I WAS A CALPERS
WHICH ELECTED SHEETS MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
CONNECTING. THEY WERE
CONNECTING VIA EVEN IF THEY'RE
USING THEIR OWN PERSONAL
DEVICE. THEY WERE ABLE TO
CONNECT TO A SECURE ENVIRONMENT
WITH AN ARC- OUR BUILDING AND
THEN ACCESS THE APPLICATION. SO
THAT IT ACCESS THE APPLICATION
pAND LAYERS OF DEFENSE- YOU HAVE
YOUR CROWN JEWELS YOUR- YOUR-
YOUR MEMBERS ARE YOUR
TAXPAYERS- I SEE THEM AS A
CENTER OF THE EARTH. AND THEN
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS A PROPER STROLLED AWAY
ACROSS THAT SO YOU HAVE THE
APPLICATION TO THE RIGHT PEOPLE
HAVE THE RIGHT ACCESS TO THE
APPLICATION- THE PEOPLE THAT A
MINISTER THAT APPLICATION WE
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE'S
IMPERSONATING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. IN ORDER TO DO IT-
VERY STINGS WITHIN THAT
APPLICATION AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT YOU HAVE. THE
THAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE
SERVERS AND NETWORKS- THE
PERIMETER. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S MULTIPLE LAYERS SO FIVE
TEN TECHNOLOGIES THAT EACH
PLAYER SO IF ONE. OF TECHNOLOGY
DOES NOT PICK IT UP THE OTHER
DOES. SO MAKING SURE. YOU HAVE
THE TECHNOLOGY AND PLACE. BUT
THEN- YOU PROBABLY HEARD THE
SAYING THAT IT'S NOT A MATTER
IF BUT WHEN- SOME SURE THE- IF.
SOME ABOUT I GUESS AND TO
ASSIST THAT THEY- IT'S SEGMENTS
THAT THERE THERE'S MINIMAL
DAMAGE- SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- ARCHITECT OUR SYSTEM
SO THAT IT IS- SEGMENTED TO A
POINT WHERE NO ONE CAN DO
MAXIMUM DAMAGE. WE WILL HAVE TO
PREVENT BATCH AND WE ALSO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- OUR TEAM
MEMBERS ARE TRAINED 290% OF ALL
DATA BREACHES ARE STILL- TIED
TO. AN INDIVIDUAL UNBEKNOWNST
EMPLOYEE THAT THEY OPEN UP AN
EMAIL LINK. THE HOUSE NUMBER ON
IT AND WHEN THEY OPEN IT UP.
THAT THAT THREAT ACTOR DOESN'T
ALWAYS NECESSARILY- DO
SOMETHING BAD RIGHT AWAY THEY
CAN SIT IN YOUR NETWORK IF
YOU'RE NOT DOING INDEPENDENT
ASSESSMENTS AND HOW CURRENT
TECHNOLOGIES. AND SO WHAT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE EDUCATED NOT TO
CLICK ON ANYTHING- SO YOU ARE
DOING INTERNAL FISHING AND
EDUCATION. AND THEN IF THEY DO
CLICK ON IT YOU WANT TO CATCH
UP WITH THE TECHNOLOGY SO
THERE'S NO DATA LEAKAGE OUTSIDE
OF HERE- STRUCTURE SO. YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SURE YOUR HOUSE BUILT
AND WHEN PEOPLE ARE ACCESSING
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY'RE
DOING IT IN THE SAME MANNER YOU
KNOW IT'S VIRTUALLY BUT THERE
HAVE THE SAME STATE OUR SYSTEM.
THEY WERE PHYSICALLY IN THE
BUILDING. WELL THAT'S HELPFUL
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR-
HELPING US UNDERSTAND BASIC.
ODD KNOWLEDGE AND I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE. COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS IN THE FUTURE AS WE
ARE EXPOSED TO THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS. I DON'T HAVE OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I'M
PREPARED TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- MY COLLEAGUES SEEM
FINE WITH THAT SO- LET ME START
RIGHT HERE- IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE WE'RE GONNA START
WITH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
TO OUR WITNESSES LET ME JUST-
DIRECT TO. YOU TO ENSURE THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING DON'T FORM A
LINE. OF THAT SORT OF THING
AND- ONCE- I ACTUALLY AM NOT
SURE I SEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE- IN SUPPORT. SO WE HAVE A
SECOND ROOM LET ME LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE. AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE OZ SO- WE
WILL TURN TO THE
TELECONFERENCE. ARE AND LET ME
INVITE THE MODERATOR TO JOIN US
AND BEFORE THEY PROP
INDIVIDUALS LET ME- SAY TO THE
WITNESSES WHO MAY BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
YOU PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND A
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
COURTROOM REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND WITH
THAT LET ME WELCOME YOU
MODERATOR TO JOIN US. THANK YOU
FISHER PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE A FEW LINES IN Q.
WITH OPERATORS GOING TO BE JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE. IT WILL GO
FIRST TIMELINE TEN. ONE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SCOTT ALTSTADT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT STATE EMPLOYEE. I HAD
THE DISTINCT PLEASURE AND HONOR
TO WORK FOR QUICKLY ANNA BAILEY
KERENS. THERE IS A WAY TO SAY
IT OTHER THAN WE ENHANCE THE
BOTTLENECK PICKING ME UP
LEADERSHIP. SHE'S A VISIONARY
INNOVATIVE COMMITTED AND
DEDICATED LEADERS. TRANSACTION
THE CAKE CHALLENGES HEAD ON. IT
SHE HERSELF BUT WILL BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST FOR CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS A CARING AND
COMPASSIONATE PERSON AND I
FULLY SUPPORT HER CONFIRMATION
THE CHIEF FOR THE OFFICE OF
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT WAS AN
EXCELLENT- I. WITNESS IN TERMS
OF THE SPEAKING SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY SO THAT'S THE MODEL
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU ALIGN. TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM GROUP AND CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ROB GROWTH WILDER AND
I'M IN A CALL. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO OUR FIRM REPRESENTS
SEVERAL TECHNOLOGY KLEIN AS
WELL THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
COUNTY GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS
I GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE APPOINTMENT I'M GONNA BE IN
THE CRIMINAL DIVISION OUT CHEAP
THE OFFICE OF TECHNOLOGY. FOR
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. ON THE DAILY
CRIMINAL EARNED AWARDS
THROUGHOUT HER STATE GOVERNMENT
CAREER- VISIONARY LEADERSHIP
AND SUCCESSFUL PROJECT. IT IS
OUR ABILITY TO EFFECTUATE
CHANGE THAT CLEARLY STANDS OUT.
SHE'S VERY ACCOMPLISHED IT
DEALING WITH EXTREMELY COMPLEX
ISSUES. AND BRINGING
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE.
BIRDS ARE POOR SOLUTIONS HE IS
NOT SHY AWAY FROM SAYING NO IF
HE DOES NOT BELIEVE IT SOLUTION
WILL NOT BENEFIT THE STATE IN
THE LONG RUN. THE DAILY
CRIMINAL KNOWS HOW TO GET
THINGS DONE ON TIME AND WITHIN
BUDGET. AND WE KNOW ABOUT HER
ABILITY TO LEAD YOUR
ORGANIZATION THROUGH CHANGE.
BUT I LIKE NO FOR THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ALSO A VERY SKEWED AND
USING HER DEPARTMENTS MOST
VALUABLE RESOURCE. THE STAFF
THE STATE DOUBLE SERVANTS
WORKING FOR CALIFORNIA ON A
DAILY BASIS. ALL MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH CURRENT AND
FORMER STATE GOVERNMENT
EXECUTIVE. AND STAFF HAVE A
CONTENT THIS. AGREEMENT NAME
COMES UP. IT IS THAT WE ON I
HAD THAT INNATE ABILITY TO
MOTIVATE TEAM MEMBERS. AND HAVE
THEM PERFORM TO THE BEST OF
THEIR ABILITY. SHE CONTINUED TO
SERVE AS A MENTOR A COACH AND
IF THERE WERE OTHER AREAS WHICH-SHE HELPED STATE EMPLOYEES.
GUARDIAN THROUGH THEIR PUBLIC
SERVICE CAREER. AND IT
MENTIONED BEFORE THE HEARING
TODAY IT'S SO EXCITING TO HAVE
ANOTHER FEMALE I KEY LEADER IN
CALIFORNIA. IS WITH NO
HESITATION. AND WE SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT. I'M INTO THIS VERY
CONDITION THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS MISTER MODERATOR. THANK
YOU MAN I'M SURE AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY. OKAY
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION. I IF THERE IS
ANYONE RIGHT HERE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THAT WANTS TO COME
FORWARD AND AGAIN I DON'T SEE
ANYONE I'M GOING TO GO BACK TO
ONE TWELVE. AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE STILL SO
MISTER MODERATOR I'M COMING
BACK TO YOU FOR MEMBERS. WHO
MAY BE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN USING
YOUR TELEPHONE YOU MAY PRESS
THE ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
HAVING LAUT ALLOWED A FEW
MOMENTS WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER%
MODERATOR WE'LL BE BACK WITH
YOU ON THE NEXT APPOINTMENT- I
AS I LOOK TO SENATOR LAYERED I
THINK I WANT TO SAY- IT'S
REALLY GOOD TO HEAR HER-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND-
EMPLOYEES OF THE STATE. REALLY
TAKE THEIR TIME TO CALL AND
WAIT AND IN SUPPORT OF OUR YOUR
LEADERSHIP YOUR RECOGNITION OF
THE VALUE OF PUBLIC SERVANTS
AND SERVICE SO. I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S NOT ALWAYS LIKE THIS I TRY
TO TELL SOME APPOINTEES US SOME
HEARINGS ARE NOT AS SMOOTH AND
EASY AND COMPLIMENTARY SOME ARE
A LITTLE ROUGHER- TO GET
THROUGH BUT- I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE IT WHEN WE GET TO
HEAR FROM PEOPLE THEIR
APPRECIATION FOR THE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND SERIOUS WORK.
THAT YOU DO SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT SENATOR LAYER OF GOODNESS
AT A BETTER IN THAT SPIRIT I
MOVED ON HER CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU SENATOR- M. SECRETARY WE
CALL THE ROLL. REMOVE KAMLAGER
ALL RIGHT LONGER I LAYERED HI I
FAITH ATKINS AYE AYE THIN SIDE
AND WE WILL LEAVE THIS ON CALL
SO THE SENATOR BATES CONJOINED
ON WHEN SHE ARRIVES- WITH OUR
APPRECIATION BUT THREE VOTES
MOVED YOU TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONFIRMATION AND- I'M SURE
YOU'LL GET THE WORD ABOUT THE
VOTE AT THE END OF SESSION BUT
FOR NOW THIS IS GREAT AND WE-
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATE YOU.
BOTH YOU- LET ME SEE IF WE ARE
GOOD TO MOVE TO ONE B. AS I
LOOK YES OKAY THANK YOU TO OUR
INCREDIBLE COURT REPORTER WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NOW TO ITEM ONE
B. AND THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT
OF SUZANNE M. MARTIN DALE J. D.
AS SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
OF THE DIVISION OF CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. SO
LET ME WELCOME YOU MISS MARTIN
DALE AND- I INVITE YOU TO ALSO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF I ANYONE
WITH YOU THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR THANK AS WELL
AS ANY OPENING COMMENTS YOU
MIGHT WANT TO MAKE AND THEN
AFTER THAT I'LL GO RIGHT TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR ATKINS MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE SUZANNE
MARTINDALE SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER FOR CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. I
KNOW THAT ARE OUT THERE
VIRTUALLY THERE ARE FAMILY
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS TODAY SO I WILL
SIMPLY SAY. THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOU BECAUSE  AM ONLY HERE
BECAUSE OF YOU. AND I WILL MOVE
ON TO MY OPENING REMARKS.
ATKINS AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
REGARDING MY APPOINTMENT AS
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION. IN
MY NEW ROLE AS SENIOR DEPUTY I
AM BUILDING A NEW CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION DIVISION.
TO IMPLEMENT OUR EXPANDED
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS THANKS TO
THE LEGISLATURE'S PASSAGE OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION WALL. I AM
TRULY HONORED AND EXCITED TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT. I PREVIOUSLY WORKED
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE AS A
POLICY EXPERT AND LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE ON CONSUMER FINANCE
ISSUES. BOTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AS NATIONALLY. I
NEGOTIATED WITH STAKEHOLDERS OF
ALL KINDS ON SEVERAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IN SACRAMENTO. MOST
NOTABLY THE NEW CCFL ITSELF. AS
A KEY ARCHITECT OF THIS LONG I
KNOW THAT IMPLEMENTATION WILL
BE A VERY COMPLEX AND
PAINSTAKING TASK. AND THAT IS
PRECISELY WHY I'M HERE BECAUSE
OF MY BELIEF IN THE WISDOM OF
THE CCI PL I BECAUSE I LOVE A
GOOD CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY WHEN
I CAN LEVERAGE ALL OF MY
EXPERIENCE. SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE IN STAKEHOLDER
RELATIONSHIPS TO HELP DRIVE
SOUND PUBLIC POLICY. THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES MARKETPLACE
IS CONSTANTLY EVOLVING AND
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO LEAD THE
WAY IN CRAFTING TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY FINANCIAL REGULATION.
HARNESSING PROMISING
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS WALL
ALSO CLOSING GAPS IN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO HELP COMMUNITIES
ACHIEVE GREATER ECONOMIC
SECURITY. TO HELP DEPARTMENT
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS I INTEND TO
BUILD UPON MY RELATIONSHIPS
WITH COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT. INCREASE PROACTIVE
ENGAGEMENT WITH COMMUNITY
GROUPS AND ENTITIES NOW SUBJECT
TO MY DIVISIONS OVERSIGHT. MAKE
SOUND POLICY DECISIONS INFORMED
BY INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL DATA
SOURCES. FOSTER COLLABORATION
WITH OTHER AGENCIES AND THE
LEGISLATURE. AND HELP DRIVE AN
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE THAT IS
COLLEGIAL AND INCLUSIVE. THANK
YOU AGAIN SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE MY HOME
STATE. IN THIS IMPORTANT NEW
WALSH AND I LOOK FOR TO
ANSWERING YOUR TO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THOSE OPENING
COMMENTS- SENATOR COM LONGER
I'M GONNA COME IN YOUR
DIRECTION TO START THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND IT IS A PLEASURE TO
SEE YOU AGAIN- MISS MARTIN DALE
I KNOW WE SPENT A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME YESTERDAY- AND- VERY
INTERESTING THIS WORK THAT IS
IN FRONT OF YOU- AND I REALLY
ONLY HAVE- TWO QUESTIONS. THE
FIRST ONE IS WHICH WE TALKED
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT YESTERDAY.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT- THE
POSSIBLE ROLE THAT- CRYPTO
CURRENCY- MAY PLAY. AND HOW WE
LIVE AND HOW WE- PROTECT HOW WE
NEGOTIATE CREDIT- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT MORE AND MORE. CITIES ARE
GETTING INTO THE CRYPTOCURRENCY
SPACE AND IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF
TIME BEFORE THOSE KINDS OF-
CONVERSATIONS ARE ELEVATED TO
THE STATE LEVEL SO LET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT. YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION- CRYPTOCURRENCY IS IN
THE NEWS A LOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
SCRATCH THEIR HEADS WHEN THEY
SEE THE WORD AND DON'T QUITE-KNOW WHAT IT IS IT IS A BLANKET
TERM. FOR A TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATION THAT IS SHOWING UP
IN MORE THAN ONE KIND OF WAY IN
FINANCIAL SERVICES ON THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT UNDERGIRDS
CRYPTO CURRENCIES COULD HAVE AN
IMPACT ON DEPOSIT TAKING AND
LENDING ONE PAYMENT PROCESSING-
AND SO THERE IS NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THAT. I HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT-
WE ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGING IN
THIS SPACE INDEED THIS IS
OUTSIDE OF MY PARTICULAR
DIVISION I DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
OF A DIRECT ROLE IN SUPERVISING
CRYPTO CURRENCY AS A TECHNOLOGY
HOWEVER IDO KNOW IN SOME OF
OUR OTHER DIVISIONS WE HAVE
SOME. LICENSEES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO CRYPTOCURRENCY AS A
SOLUTION TO THEIR BUSINESS
MODEL I AND WE HAVE TO TAKE A
MEASURED APPROACH HERE BECAUSE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE FACETS TO
CRYPTOCURRENCY GET BECAUSE IT
SHOWS UP IN FINANCIAL SERVICES
IN MORE THAN ONE WAY WE NEED
TO. TAKE A MEASURED APPROACH.
LOOK CASE BY CASE. I HAVE A
PARTICULAR. USE CASE- TO THE
PATH. AND SO THERE ARE SOME BIG
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW TO REGULATE
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH AND REGULARLY
TALK WITH OUR STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS BECAUSE THIS ALTHOUGH
MANY OF THESE COMPANIES OUR
HOUSE RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE NOT JUST STATEWIDE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE GROWTH OF
THIS MARKET BUT THERE ARE
ATIONAL AND ACTUALLY EVEN
INTERNATIONAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
HEALTH FINANCIAL REGULATORS GET
THEIR ARMS AROUND. THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND DETERMINE. HOW
BEST TO REGULATE DONE BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY. AS WITH
ANY OTHER INNOVATION WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WHERE THERE ARE
BENEFITS ARE THAT WE ARE
KNOWLEDGE DOES BUT WE ALWAYS
NEED TO ENSURE. THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS ARE
NOT CREATING SYSTEMIC RISK OR
POSING HARM TO CONSUMERS
BECAUSE WE DO NOT WANT A
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO COME
FROM OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. TO BE GUINEA PIGS
FOR SO TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
SO THERE REALLY IS A DELICATE
BALANCING ACT THERE- BUT AGAIN
WE ARE TAKING. A VERY MEASURED
APPROACH AND GATHERING THAT
DATA AND I ANTICIPATE THAT AS
WE LEARN MORE AND AS WE ENGAGE
MORE WITH STAKEHOLDERS ARE
THINKING WILL OF ALL AND OUR
POLICY WILL FALL ALONG THE WAY.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT. IT'S
BEEN ON MY MIND MOSTLY BECAUSE-
CITIES- IN FLORIDA FOR EXAMPLE
AND IN SOME OTHER STATES. ARE
NOW ALLOWING. CRYPTO CURRENCY
TO BE USED TO PAY FOR- CITY
SERVICES. AND SO I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE THAT THAT IS SOMETHING.
THAT OTHER CITIES AND OTHER
STATES WILL BEGIN TO LOOK INTO
SO I ALWAYS THINK IT'S GOOD. TO
BE IN FRONT OF THE EIGHT BALL
RATHER THAN. BUT IT I CERTAINLY
A- EXPERTISE INTHE CONSUMER
PROTECTION SPACE I THINK- WE
NEED MORE OF IT AND- THERE'S
BEEN SOME GOOD BILLS. THAT
HAVE- PAST- IN THIS LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PROTECTING OUR- CONSUMERS.
ARE WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME GOOD FAITH ACTORS SOME
GOOD FAITH LENDERS. IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE PLAYING BY
OUR RULES. BUT WITH SOME
ADVANCES IN THE- FINANCIAL
TECHNOLOGY. AS AT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS CAN JUST GO- ONLINE
OR GO OUT OF STATE AND SO WHAT
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW YOU
CAN PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS AND
ELEVATE AND SUPPORT ARE OF GOOD
FAITH CALIFORNIA LENDERS. YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION THAT IS OUR MISSION
NOW IS DO YOU HAVE P. I. VERY
VERY CLEARLY STATED. IN THE C.
C. F. P. L. WE HAVE A DUAL
MISSION TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND FOSTER RESPONSIBLE
INNOVATION WHEN TECHNOLOGY
OUTPACES THE LAW AS IT. IS WANT
TO DO- THERE CAN BE A CONUNDRUM
FROM UNFAIR COMPETITION
STANDPOINT WHERE THERE IS
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY THERE
COULD BE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF RESPONSIBLE INNOVATORS NOT
KNOWING WHICH RULES ARE
SUPPOSED TO PLAY BY WHICH CAN
INFORM ATTENTION INHERIT THEIR
INVESTMENT DECISIONS ALSO FOR
RULE AT THE DEPARTMENT IS TO
ENSURE. THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING
DATA AND STAKEHOLDER PROACTIVE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WITH
FOLKS ON ALL SIDES NOT JUST
COMMUNITY GROUPS BUT ALSO WITH
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THE WORK
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THERE ARE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES AND CONCERNS
ARE BECAUSE AS WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND UPDATE OUR
REGULATIONS INFORMED BY DATA
AND STAKEHOLDER INPUT WE HAVE A
REAL OPPORTUNITY. TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AND ENSURE THAT
RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE BETTER.
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WHO NEED IT
MOST. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR OUR RESPONSES AND LOOK FOR
TO HEAR A- CONFIRMATION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I ENJOYED TALKING WITH YOU THIS
MORNING AND IT JUST ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION IF WE- TALKED ABOUT
THIS MORNING. YOU INDICATED
THAT YOUR DID YOUR DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH THE DRAFTING OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION LAW. AND I
WAS GOING TO ASK IF THE LAW HAS
CONFORM TO YOUR EXPECTATIONS
THUS FAR- HAVE YOU SEEN
ANYTHING THAT WAS ON
ANTICIPATED OR- CREATES A GAP
THAT YOU THINK SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE QUESTION THE LAW IS
VERY COMPREHENSIVE AND WE ARE
STILL IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
IMPLEMENTATION. WHAT IS I THINK
VERY WHAT'S VERY POWERFUL ABOUT
IT AND WHAT IS SO EXCITING
ABOUT IT IS A TO PROVIDE US
WITH BROAD AND FLEXIBLE SUBJECT
MATTER JURISDICTION AS A
GENERAL MATTER OVER PROVIDERS
OF FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES SO IT GIVES US THE
ROOM WE NEED. TO IDENTIFY RISKS
IDENTIFYING GAPS AND REGULATORY
UNCERTAINTY ALREADY THAT WE CAN
THEN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF JUST AS
I WAS PREVIOUSLY STATING
THERE'S A LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD PROVIDE BETTER CLARITY HI
TECH INDUSTRY AT THE END OF THE
DAY PROTECT CONSUMERS ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
IMPLEMENTATION WILL TAKE A LOT
OF WORK WE ARE IN THE EARLY
STAGES WE WILL HAVE TO SEE
WHERE WE ARE IN A FEW YEARS
TIME- BUT I AM PLEASED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WORKING AND I IN
GOOD FAITH WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SO
COLLABORATIVELY CONSTRUCTIVELY
LAST YEAR. UNDER ALL OF THE
STRANGE CIRCUMSTANCES WE WERE
LIVING AND I WAS ABLE TO COME
TOGETHER TO PASS THIS AND IT IS
A IT'S A TRULY EXCITING TIME TO
JUDGE TO BE AT THE DEPARTMENT
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DIALOGUE. WITH THE LEGISLATURE-
AS. THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
AND WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU IS THAT MOVES
ALONG SO THAT. WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT IF THERE ARE GAPS OR-
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE WORK
ON THEM TOGETHER- THANK YOU MAN
FIRST. THANK YOU SENATOR AND
DIES ACTUALLY IN YOUR
EXPLANATION YOU ANSWERED THE
ONE QUESTION I HAD WHEN YOU
WERE RESPONDING TO SENATOR COM
LAGER JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
SO- AS A REMINDER I'M GOING TO
HAVE THE NUMBER PUT UP AGAIN.
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE OUR
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE THE ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE. AND SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND-
WONDERFUL WE HAVE A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC HERE WITH US IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- WE HAVE
MISSED YOU. MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. WELCOME LET ME ASK YOU
THAT YOU KNOW THE ROUTINE I
RECOGNIZE YOU SO I'D YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION IF IT
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOUR
POSITION WELCOME. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IT'S IMMENSELY
GRATIFYING TO SEE YOU HERE IN
PERSON- MY NAME IS MIKE CANOED
SIN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
OPPORTUNE I'M ALSO HERE IN MY
INDIVIDUAL CASTING CAPACITY IS
A LONGTIME FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
OF MS MARTIN THEY'LL- I'VE BEEN
ON- AND WE HAVE BEEN ON BOTH.
IN THE TRENCHES WITH HER
FIGHTING ON ISSUES WE'VE ALSO
BEEN ACROSS THE TABLE WORKING
ON ON BRIDGING GAPS- SHE IS-
SMART. FAIR FIERCELY DEDICATED
CONSUMER ISSUES ON A NATIONAL
EXPERT IN SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
YOU CAN HEAR THE PASSION IN HER
VOICE AS SHE AS SHE TESTIFIES
IN THIS COMMITTEE. AND SHE IS
VERY FORMIDABLE IN OUR OWN
RIGHT. ALL OF THESE
CHARACTERISTICS MAKE HER AN
EXCELLENT CHOICE AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT HER
MUCH OKAY. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
I'M GOING TO TURN TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I DON'T SEE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN ONE TWELVE SO I'M
GOING TO WELCOME BACK OUR
MODERATOR MR MODERATOR- WELCOME
IF YOU WOULD PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SHARE YOUR POSITION
OF SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO WHEN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE.
WE HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q. GO
FIRST ONLINE EIGHTEEN THAT'S
ONE EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE I AM REASONABLE
CHORUS BUT THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF A BROAD COALITION
OF CONSUMER AND BUSINESS
ADVOCATE WHO WOULD DO THE
ATHLETES REPORT. OVER HER
CAREER MISS MARTIN BUILDING
DEMONSTRATED HER STRONG
COMMITMENT TO ECONOMIC JUSTICE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS- SHIP
POLICY EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE
IN WORKING WITH A WIDE RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS BALANCED APPROACH
TO POLICY IS AN INVALUABLE
ASSET FOR THE FBI. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HER AS SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THIRTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
MARGARET CLANCY NUMBER HALF OF
REDUCE POTENTIAL AND PLEASED TO
SUPPORT MARTINGALES APPOINTMENT
THIS AFTERNOON AT SHE HAS BEEN
FAIR AND REASONABLE IN MANY OF
MY DEALINGS WITH HER AND I HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
HER IN HER AT YOUR PAST
POSITION AS WELL AS HER CURRENT
POSITION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AND SHE IS
CONFIRMED TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT THIS IS
ONE OF THE CALL THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK WHICH REPRESENTS MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY
COMMUNITY BANKS ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE MANAGER JOHN
SUPPORT AND THEN RIGHT NOW AS-
WE NEED. SURE OF THE DETAILS. I
THINK BE MARK PROTECTION AT THE
FBI. AND BECAUSE OF HER MANY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WORKING ON
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
ISSUES. AND HER KNOWLEDGE OF
CALIFORNIANS FINANCIAL. LAWS
AND REGULATIONS. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT EXPERIENCE THAT ALIGNS
WITH THE MISSION AND THE FBI
AND WILL BE INVALUABLE AS IT.
CONTINUES TO RAMP UP AND WE ARE
EXCITED TO WORK WITH HER AND
FOR COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. LINE. TWENTY GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
TRODDEN ON BEHALF OF THE
DEMERGER CALIFORNIA AND WE'D
LIKE TO LINE OUR COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS QUARTERS FOR THE
MARTINGALE CONFIRMATION THEN
COMBINE STRONG STAKEHOLDER
RELATIONSHIPS AND ABILITY TO
COLLABORATE FORGET RESULTS IN
HAS THE EXPERTISE NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT COMPLEX LEGISLATION
WE APPRECIATE IN VALUE WITHIN
STRONG COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC
SERVICE THE NURTURER
APPOINTMENTS. HERE DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER CHECK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS- TWENTY ONE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON PRESIDENT IN THE
MEETING MY NAME IS HEIDI
PICKMAN FROM CAMEO CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY WHERE
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF MISSION
DRIVEN ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE FREE LOW COST BUSINESS
SERVICES AND AFFECT CAPITAL
UNDERSERVED BUSINESS OWNERS I
AM VOICING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SUSAN MARTIN DALE AS THE
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER FOR
THE DIVISION OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION.
AND INNOVATION. ANY SMALL
BUSINESSES OUT CONSUMERS WHEN
IT COMES TO LOOKING UP THEIR
FINANCING OPTIONS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'M GRATEFUL
NEWS MARTINGALE RECOGNIZE. WHEN
WE DISCUSSED IT AS THE FBI WITH
BEING CREATED. NEWMARKET DEL
COLLABORATIVE AND PASSIONATE
INTERFACE YOU UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES AND UNDERSTATE.
UNDERSTATE STAND THAT WHILE
INNOVATION CAN BENEFIT
CONSUMERS AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
FOR EXAMPLE INCREASED ACCESS TO
CAPITAL THE BEIJING CAN ALSO
ALLOW PREDATORY PRACTICES- TO
COME ABOUT AND PRINT SOMEWHAT
PROLIFERATE. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MR
MARTIN DOWN THE PROTECT OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES FROM PRACTICES
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO RUIN
OUR MAIN STREET WE- URGE YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MINE. FIFTEEN
ONE FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RENO
FERNANDES AND I'M A BUSINESS
ATTORNEY IN CALIFORNIA I'VE
KNOWN MISS MARTIN DEAL FOR
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS SHE DID NOT
KNOW I WOULD BE CALLING IN
MAKING A STATEMENT SO THIS IS A
SURPRISE. I WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT SHE IS DEDICATED
SHE'S A TIRELESS PROFESSIONAL
AND JUST IT INCREDIBLE ASSET
FOR THE STATE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE STATE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY
LUCKY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OTHER WITNESSES MISTER
MODERATOR. WE DO HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL LINE IN Q. WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE OUR NEXT
COMMENT AS FROM LINE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TED
MERMAN- FROM THE UC BERKELEY
LAW SCHOOL MISS MARTIN DALE
SAMA MODER. I'M SPEAKING AT THE
END IN MY INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY
ON THAT ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US
AT THE UC BERKELEY TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT. FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT AND OUR ADMIRATION
FOR THE APPOINTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OUR OTHER WITNESSES
MISTER MODERATOR. NO NO OR THE
LINES INTO AT THS TIME THANK
YOU- WILL BE BACK IN A MOMENT
WITH YOU I OKAY I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS TO HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION I WILL START IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
SEE NO FURTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE I WILL TAKE A LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE ARE. ALSO NO
ONE THERE SO- MISTER MODERATOR
I AM BACK WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
TO STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
APPOINTMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON OUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD HMI PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
SO MUCH ARE WE WILL AGAIN TALK
WITH YOU IN A FEW MINUTES- LET
ME THANK- THOSE WHO CALLED IN-
AS WITNESSES WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
COLLEAGUES- FOR ANYTHING
FURTHER. ARE A MOTION. SENATOR
COM LONGER THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION AND- ARE YOU MADAM- VICE
CHAIR YES I THINK THAT YOU- I'M
SORRY THAT I MISSED THE FIRST
PART OF THE DISCUSSION AND I
DON'T WANT TO BE REDUNDANT
QUESTIONS I JUST HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT THE- FAIR ENOUGH BUT
TRANSPARENCY- FOR THE
UNREGULATED INDUSTRIES- BECAUSE
THEY ARE NEWLY- UNDER THE V.
OF. REGULATION OF THE FOR A
PARTICULAR AGENCY AND WONDERING.
UP WITHOUT QUESTION ASKED. I
WAS IT WAS NO IS THERE ANY
GUIDANCE GIVEN TO THEM- AND HOW
THE- REGULATIONS AND THE
ENFORCEMENT WILL BE- ADOPTED IN
AND IMPLEMENTED- WOULD YOU
LIKE- MISS MARTIN DEAL TO GO
AHEAD AYE IT WHICH IS AYE AND
ANSWER RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION.
CERTAINLY JUST GIVE ME A QUICK.
QUICK VIEW OF HOW YOU'RE
REACHING OUT TO THOSE AGENTS
THOSE PARTICULAR UP AND
REGULATED INDUSTRIES AND NAY ON
JOB THEIR RESPONSE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT WAS THE THING
OF MOST CONCERN IF I. DID MY
READING BEFORE I WAS ABLE TO BE
HERE THIS MORNING. YES THANK
YOU CENTER ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION I AFTER THE THIS
IS BEFORE I ARRIVED BUT AFTER
NO NEW LAW WAS PASSED THE
DEPARTMENT DID HOLD. INITIAL
LISTENING SESSIONS PRECISELY TO
YOUR POINT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WAS NOT WOULD BE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR COMPANIES WHO NOW MAY BE
SUBJECT TO OUR JURISDICTION. TO
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF THE
NEW AUTHORITIES UNDER THE LAW
AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS. EVER SINCE THEN AND
CERTAINLY SINCE MY ARRIVAL I
HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS- IN- WHO ARE
ENTITIES THAT WILL NOW BE EACH
POTENTIALLY SUBJECT TO OUR
JURISDICTION- WE MEET
REGULARLY. WE HAVE ALSO BE
SHOOT OUR INVITATION TO COMMENT
ON- ON A POTENTIAL REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD CLARIFY WHO NOW
NEEDS TO BE SUBJECT TO
REGISTRATION WHICH IS OUR
SUPERVISION HAWK. UNDER THE NEW
WALL I'LL BE PUT ON THE
INVITATION FOR COMMENT EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE RECEIVED A FEW
DOZEN THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
INVITATIONS TO COMMENT COMING
SO WE ARE SOLICITING A MULTIPLE
TOUCHPOINTS. EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDER INPUT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WERE PROVIDING THE
GUIDANCE THAT THAT INDUSTRIS
NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW WE'RE
TAKING A MEASURED DATA DRIVEN.
MULTI STOP APPROACH TO GET
THERE HOPE THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO
YOUR QUESTION IT DOESN'T THANK
YOU FOR THAT I THINK ARE YOU.
TODAY I'M JUST GOING TO
ABSTAINED ABOUT CONTINUE MY
REVIEW OF THE FOR FIVE HAD.
CONCERNS RAISED BY INDIVIDUALS
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT I
WANT TO BE COMFORTABLE BEFORE I
YOU KNOW VOTE SO. I UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT IS NOT. IN ANY WAY
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT YOU COME TO
THIS- ASSIGNMENT. WITH AN
EXCELLENT RESUME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MATTER VICE CHAIR ARE
THERE THE MOST BY SO COM
LOCKERS MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ROVE HAVE LONGER
HI KAMLAGER ARE LAYERED AYE AYE
BATES. DAN ABSTAINED ATKINS
FIVE I CAN FIVE THREE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE YOU ARE
CONFIRMED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE OR WE WILL MOVE YOUR
CONFIRMATION TO THE SENATE
FLOOR AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU I'M
WE ARE GOING TO- TAKE FIVE
MINUTES AND I WILL OPEN THE
ROLE TO ADD- OUR VICE CHAIR ON
WHEN WE COME BACK AND GIVE HER
THE TOM- FOR THAT SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE FIVE MINUTES WILL BE
BACK SHORTLY. THANK YOU.
ORDER. AND BEFORE WE WELCOME
OUR- FINAL APPOINTEE REQUIRED
TO APPEAR. I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND ASK- MADAM SECRETARY IF SHE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM TO.
D. E. F. AND G. FOR THE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT BATES FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO FOUR ZERO THANK YOU- THOSE
APPOINTMENTS ARE. OUT ITEMS- WE
TOOK ITEMS THREE AND FOUR THE
BILL REFERRALS AND SELECT
COMMITTEE REQUEST- TOGETHER
MADAM VICE CHAIR WOMAN- CAN YOU
OPEN THE ROLE. BATES AYE FAITH
AYE FORTY ZERO WONDERFUL THANK
YOU AND I THINK THAT IS IT SO
WE WILL GO. ONE MORE ONE A- OH
OH GOLLY THANK YOU SEE THIS IS
WHY I HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
SECRETARY. OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM ONE A. WE VOTED
ON BEFORE YOU GOT HERE MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND THAT. WAS MISS
BINGLEY CRIMMINS TO THE CHIEF
AS CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES DEPARTMENT
OF TECHNOLOGY SO WE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON ITEM ONE A. EIGHT.
HI IT'S ALL RIGHT FORTY ZERO
FOUR TO ZERO I'M SURE SHE WILL
BE THRILLED TO HEAR. THAT AND
WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO- THE
LAST APPOINTMENT AND THAT WOULD
BE DR MARIA GUADALUPE HIGH ME-
MY LAMB. AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SO LET ME FIRST
AND FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE. AND LET ME
WELCOME YOU AND OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS- ACKNOWLEDGE OR THANK
ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE TO- AND
AFTER YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
WILL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS WELCOME DOCTOR. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU PRESIDENT PRO
TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MADDIE OUT
BUT I WILL FACE TIME IN MY LIFE
AND I'M THE DEPUTY. DIRECTOR OF
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UPON MY
EXPERIENCE AND EXPAND MY
ABILITY TO SERVE CALIFORNIA'S
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
OUR SERVICES ESPECIALLY WITHIN
THE NEW NEWLY ESTABLISHED
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION. WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES I
APPRECIATE THE TRUST THAT
GOVERNOR NUISANCE SECRETARY
GOLLY AND DIRECTOR JOHNSON
HAPPENED AND ASKING ME TO SERVE
IN THIS CAPACITY. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK MY HUSBAND MAP
YOU DAVID MY LAMB MY DAUGHTER
ALEXIS WHEN I LOOK BACK I MEAN
THIS MY PARENTS FEDERAL AND
NATALIA HIGH MAY AS WELL AS MY
SIBLINGS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
FEDERAL ALEXANDRA YES PLEASE
AND THE ANA FOR THEIR
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE AND SUPPORT
I HOPE TO CONTINUE AND ALWAYS
MAKE THEM PROUD AND I WILL
REFERENCE THAT THEY ARE HAVING
A LARGE PARTY OR VIRTUAL WATCH
PARTY AT THIS TIME. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE ADDITIONAL PEOPLE
IN MY VILLAGE THAT INCLUDES
FRIENDS MENTORS. COLLEAGUES
STAFF. TELL PROVIDER HELLO THE
WAY HELP SHAPE WHO I. THANK TO
GROW AS A LEADER. FINALLY I AM
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR MY CDSS
FAMILY WHO HAVE PROVIDED ME
ONGOING ASSISTANCE GRACE
EXPERTISE TO BUILD A SOLID
FOUNDATION FOR THIS HISTORIC
WORK ACROSS OUR SYSTEM. FOR THE
LAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK FOR A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
CENTRAL VALLEY CHILDREN'S
SERVICES NETWORK AND FRESNO AS
WELL AS FRESNO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS. AND
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
URBINA I DIRECTLY OPERATED MANY
OF THE CONTRACTS THAT ARE
TRANSFERRING TO CDSS BEFORE.
HAVING TO CDSS MY INTENT IS TO
USE THIS EXPERIENCE TO ASSESS
DIRECTOR JOHNSON AND LEADING
THE NEW DIVISION TO ADDRESS
INSTITUTIONAL BARRIERS SO
FAMILIES CAN ACCESS QUALITY
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE'S. INTEGRATE THE NEW
DIVISION WITHIN THE CDSS
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE STATE THE
NEXT PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT
FAMILIES FROM UNTIL GENERATION
APPROACH THIS IS KEY FOR
PROVIDING ECONOMIC MOBILITY FOR
OUR FAMILIES. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK OUR LEGISLATOR CHAMPIONS
ALL OF THE WONDER STAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT INVESTMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THIS MY
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR LET ME
MADAM VICE CHAIR LET ME START
WITH YOU THIS TIME WELL THANK
YOU. ME GET MY- THANK YOU
DOCTOR I NEED MILK I THINK THAT
TRUTHFULLY I HOLD- I WANT TO
THANK YOU ARE LOOKING AT YOUR
RESUME AND THANK YOU FOR MANY
MANY YEARS THAT YOU'VE PUT INTO
THIS SO VERY IMPORTANT. ARENA
OF- A CHILDREN AND FAMILY IF I
WAS ONCE UPON A TIME A SOCIAL
WORKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THIRTY NOT A WITHIN
THE LONG BEACH OFFICE FOR MANY
YEARS AND ALSO IN THE SOUTHEAST
L. A. OFFICE FOR A COUPLE A
YEAR SO- VERY VERY- DIFFICULT-
YEARS I THINK. WITH THAT
PARTICULAR- HI MEGAN ARE FIVE.
ONE OF THE OLDER FOLKS HERE.
BUT IF THE BALLOT SELECTION
DIFFICULT SUSAN ADVANCEMENT
MOVING OUR- CHILD CARE SERVICES
UNDER CDF AND AWAY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO. LET
ME ASK YOU A DO YOU THINK WE
NEED TO BE CONCERNED THAT OF.
ANY OF THE- EDUCATIONAL. UNEVEN
OPPORTUNITIES OF OUR CHILDREN
UP WOULD BE AFFECTED BY PUTTING
IT SPECIFICALLY AND DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
VERSUS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- A MINOR CONCERN BUT
CERTAINLY ONE I THINK THAT. ARE
NEED TO BE ASKING YOU I LOOK TO
YOU- CERTAINLY OF AN EXPERT- ON
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MEET ENSURE
THAT THE CHILD CARE IN THE
EDUCATION. OF OUR OUR
YOUNGSTERS ARE A FEEL. SEAMLESS
FUND TOGETHER AND PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES. CERTAINLY AREN'T
FOR GROWTH. IT'S THANK YOU SAN
PER YEAR FAST- IN REGARDS TO-
THE ROLE OF EDUCATION FRIGHTENS
HOW CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS AND I BOTH FOR YEAR AT
THAT TIME WHEN WE THINK OF OUR
CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND IT AND-
THAT'S HOW DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WE HAVE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
EDUCATION IS EMBEDDED WITHIN
THIS PROGRAM. CARE AND
EDUCATION GO HAND IN HAND THIS
WILL. THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE TOUCH SO MUCH IN
THESE EARLY YEARS BASED ON THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE ACT
LIFESPANS. AS WE LOOK AT ARE
MOVING FORWARD AND YOU. TALKED
ABOUT THE SCENE THE
STREAMLINING ACT TOGETHER I
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE VERY
CRITICAL FOR CVE NCSS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
HAPPEN INTEGRATION HAPPENING WE
MODEL THAT NICELY DURING THIS
TRANSITION YEAR. PRIOR TO THIS
TRANSITION YEAR WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO WORK
TOGETHER AND POST THE
TRANSITION WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS ARE IN SEEK TO HAVE
THAT SEAMLESS TRANSFER FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN. WELL I
THINK- YOU SAID YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE IT ON TRACK AS SOON AS
SADDAM STARTED JULY FIRST
THAT'S FOURTEEN DAYS THEN. ANY
BUMPS ALONG THAT ROAD YEAH. YES
SO THAT WAS DEFINITELY A SHORT
TERM GOAL RIGHT THAT. MILESTONE
OF JULY FIRST AND- YOU SEE
THERE THERE'S ALWAYS FUN. WHEN
YOU ARE TRANSITIONING- SUCH A
LARGE- DIVISION FROM ONE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY INTO ANOTHER-
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE THAT JULY
FIRST IS HERE THAT THAT-
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE POSITION UP ALREADY-
POSITIONS AND SOME OF THOSE
ARE. OUR BILL WOULD HAVE TO
COME OVER TO CDSS WE ARE
TAPPING INTO THEIR- THEIR
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE TO
HELP SHAPE THE SUBMISSION AND
WE ALSO SUCCESSFULLY WERE ABLE
TO USE SENSE- CONTRACTS THE
CONTRACTS OUT TO THE
CONTRACTORS TUNES. SURE THAT
NATO DESTRUCTION OCCURRED
WITHIN. THE SERVICES AT. THE
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN ARE
RECEIVING. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS HAVE ANOTHER CONCERN
BUT I'M GOING TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE I BELIEVE I
HAVE SOMETHING THAT ON ALL OUR
MINDS AND DADDY- SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO THE CHILD CARE
SERVICES. THAT WERE SO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED OUR
DURING THE PANDEMIC POTS
PEOPLE. TELL THEIR SERVICE OF-
NOT AVAILABLE TO OUR BOB PARENT
TO PARENT TO WORKING FAMILIES
AND ALSO- TOO MANY MANY PEOPLE
EMPLOYED IN THAT- AS CERTAINLY
A CAREER PATH. IN A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ONE SO I'LL DEFER
THAT I'M SURE IT'LL COME UP
AGAIN FOR MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
BRAIDED QUESTIONS AND JUST
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR. A NUMBER
OF YEARS THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ENOUGH AND CERTAINLY
HAVE HANDS ON KNOWLEDGE AS YOU
FOR WORK THROUGH ODDS AND MANY
DIFFERENT DIMENSIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT ANDI WILL BE ARE
SUPPORTING. YOUR CONFIRMATION
APPOINTMENT- SENATOR COM LONGER
I'M TO GO TO IN THE OF THAT YOU
HAVE TO LEAVE FOR A HEALTH
COMMITTEE- SO IF YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD SURE THANK YOU ARE. MADAM
CHAIR I WANNA THANK YOU- DR
MYLAN FOR THE TIME THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO SPEND- YESTERDAY I
THINK IT WAS OUR MONDAY I CAN'T
EVEN REMEMBER ANYMORE BUT
REALLY DELIGHTED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU-
AND REALLY EXCITED ABOUT- YOUR
CONFIRMATION- AS I SHARED WITH
YOU I THINK IT'S SO INCREDIBLE.
AND INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO BE IN THIS
POSITION SO MANY OF OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE WOMEN THEY
ARE FEMALE ENTREPRENEURS AND
THEY ARE WOMEN OF COLOR- AND IT
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
HAVE REPRESENTATION IN THIS
SPACE IN GOVERNMENT. SO THAT
THEY FEEL THAT THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND THEIR
FRUSTRATIONS ARE ANCHORED IN A
REALITY THAT SOMEONE
ACKNOWLEDGES SO I'M REALLY
EXCITED- AND I WANTED TO SAY
THAT'S AND YOU SAID YOU HAD A
WATCH PARTY IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
GET A LITTLE YOU KNOW LOVE WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT. WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY
AND I WOULD JUST LOVE TO. HAVE
YOU RESPOND TO IT AGAIN YOU
KNOW I SHARED WITH YOU MY
THOUGHTS ON TEEKAY. OUT WE KNOW
THAT IT IS COMING I KNOW THAT
IT IS NOT UNDER YOUR DIRECT
PURVIEW. BUT YOU KNOW AS I
SHARED WITH YOU I BELIEVE THAT
THE T. K. EXPANSION WILL
DIRECTLY. IMPACT THE ABILITY
FOR- COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS.
TO STAY IN BUSINESS AND TO
SERVE. OUR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES- WE KNOW THAT FOUR
YEAR OLDS ARE THE MONEY MAERS
THEY PAY THE BILLS FOR. OUR
CHILD CARE CENTERS. BECAUSE
INFANT CARE INFANT AND TODDLER
CARE IS INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE.
AND THE CONCERN THAT MANY
PROVIDERS- AND ADVOCATES IN THE
SPACE HAVE SHARED. IS THAT IF
THERE IS AN ACCIDENT A FOUR
YEAR OLDS- INTO A T. K.
PROGRAM. WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THESE PROVIDERS WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING AND GRINDING
IT OUT FOR YEARS AND YEARS
TAKING CARE OF OUR CHILDREN AND
PROVIDING THEM. THE ECT- THAT
IS SO CRITICAL FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR YOUNG
MINDS AND THEIR BODIES- YOU
KNOW CHOICES NOT CHOICE. IF THE
FUNDING IS ONLY FOR ONE KIND OF
SETTING. AND SO IT MAKES
DELIVERY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT AND HAVING A SYSTEM
THAT RECOGNIZES THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF WORKING PARENTS. IF
YOU HAVE CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS PARENTS TO WORK OFF HOURS
PARENTS WHO NEED TWENTY FOUR
HOUR CARE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
HAVE TO BE PART OF THE EQUATION
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
APPROPRIATELY FUNDING CHILD
CARE AND REALLY SORT OF AN
INVESTING IN INFRASTRUCTURE IN
A FRAMEWORK THAT EGGMAN
KNOWLEDGES THE REALITIES OF ALL
OF THE FAMILIES THAT COMPRISE
CALIFORNIA AND NEED CARE. SO
JUST WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW
WE ARE GOING TO. ESERVER THIS
MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM. WHEN
GIVEN THE POTENTIAL- THAT
THERE'S AN EXODUS OF FOUR YEAR
OLDS WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE OUR
OUR LICENSE EXAM PROVIDERS IN
OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES-
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE TRENCHES
FOR A REALLY LONG TIME AND
PROBABLY FEEL LIKE WERE
DESERTING THEM. GRANTED WE GOT
RIGHT REFORM GRANTED WE HAVE
THE S. R. R. IN THE ARM ARE
COMING- AND WE ARE YOU KNOW
DOUBLING DOWN IN THAT SPACE
BUT- THERE IS CONCERN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS AS WELL AS YOUR
QUESTION- LET'S FIRST START BY.
KNOWLEDGE IN THE IMPORTANT.
ROLE PASSED THE NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM HAS IN REGARDS TO OUR
FAMILIES ACCESSING CARE AND
BEING ABLE TO MAINTAIN THEIR
JOBS ESPECIALLY AROUND
POSITIONS THAT ARE NOT OUR
TRADITIONAL HOURS RIGHT OUTSIDE
OF EIGHTY FIVE WHICH MANY PARK
FAMILIES HEAT. ON DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WE REALLY HIGHLIGHTED
THAT MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM
WHICH I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY
CALL OUT BECAUSE IT'S A TERM
THAT WE USE. BUT WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
IT IS OUR FAMILY FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS AS WELL AS OUR- OUR
OUR CENTER BASED CARE AND OUR-
LICENSE FAMILY TALK HER HOME
PROVIDERS. AND SO HAVING THAT
MIX DELIVER SYSTEM INTACT I
MENTIONED IS CRUCIAL AND IT BUT
IT REALLY SUPPORTS OUR PARENTS
HAVE PRINCE WITH CHOICE TO BE
ABLE TO. WRAP AROUND CARE AS
THEIR NEEDS AS THEY IDENTIFY
THEIR NEEDS AS WELL AS LOOKING
AT IT FROM CULTURE AS WELL AS
LOOKING AT IT FOR WHAT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THEM. SO THAT
VERY CRITICAL I WOULD
UNDERSCORE WHAT YOU SHARED WITH
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION THERE'S
A COUPLE PIECES THAT WE HAVE TO
BE MINDFUL WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT- THE NEXT DELIVERY SYSTEM
AND MAINTAIN THAT. WHEN THIS
COORDINATION IS KEY. WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CUP
COLLABORATION AND MEETINGS WITH
OUR CITY PARTNERS- HAVING QUICK
CONVERSATIONS IN REGARDS TO THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT
OUR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
TRANSFERRED OVER TO CBS FAST.
NOT ONLY WRAP AROUND THE T. K.
OPTION. ASSUMING THAT PARENTS
WOULD WANT TO CHOOSE THAT TO-
BUT ALSO THAT IT'S A SEAMLESS
WRAP AROUND. HOW TO ENSURE THAT
PARENTS ARE NOT ONLY AND
ROLLING WITH OUR PROGRAM BUT-ARE ARE AWARE OF OTHER OPTIONS
AS WELL AS- IF THEY'RE ENROLLED
IN TKA PROGRAMS THEY'RE ALSO
SHARED ABOUT OTHER SERVICES
AROUND THE CHILD AND
DEVELOPMENT. EFFICIENT THAT IS
GOING TO B. MUTUAL CONVERSE
THAT HAD BEFORE A CONTINUE TO
HAVE. AN BE ABLE TO SERVE THAT
BUT SOME GUY AROUND THAT. THE
SECOND THING I WILL CALL OUT TO
BEING PARENTAL CHU. PRINTER
CHOICES CRITICAL HERE MANY OF
OUR CONTRACTORS AS WELL AS OUR
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEMS ARE STRONG
ADVOCATES TO ENSURE THAT
PARENTS KNOW THAT THAT PRINTER
CHAU SUCCESS AND MAKE THEM
AWARE OF WHAT. IT MEANS TO HAVE
PRINCE WITH CHOICE AND SO
CONTINUE TO HAPPENS PROVIDE
SOME GUIDANCE TO THE FIELD IN
THAT AREA WILL BE IMPORTANT
ALSO. AND THEN FINALLY AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT BUILDING OUT THIS
MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM WITH
HAPPY A GREATER PRESENCE OF TKA
WE ALSO WANT TO BE MINDFUL THAT
ARE STAKEHOLDERS THAT INCLUDES
OUR LICENSE PROVIDERS. AS WELL
AS OTHERS REALLY DO YOU HAVE
SOLUTIONS PRESS OF HOW THIS CAN
WORK AND SO WE ARE STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MAKE TIME TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND BRING THAT
VOICE BACK INTO THE SYSTEM THAT
WE'RE DEVELOPING COLLECTIVELY.
THAT I THINK WILL BRING THEM. A
STRONGER MAKES DELIVERY SYSTEM.
GREAT YEAH THANK YOU THAT I AM
AS I SHARE WITH YOU I SPENT A
NUMBER OF YEARS THAT CRYSTAL
STAIRS WE HAD A CHILD CARE
CENTER- WE WORK WITH LICENSED
AND LICENSE EXEMPT PROVIDERS
AND WE TOOK CARE FAMILIES THAT
WERE STAGE ONE STAGE TO STAGE
THREE- AND AT. EIGHT P. AND HAD
IN OUR IN OUR- THIS IS A SPACE
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE- THE SAYING IS TRUE
CHILD CARE KEEPS CALIFORNIA
WORKING AND WE HAVE GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN IT AND SUPPORT FROM ITS
DELIVERY SYSTEM. THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES OF THE UNIQUE
NEEDS AND CULTURAL AND- UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVES OF OUR FAMILY SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR- AGREEING
TO SERVE IN THIS ROLE. THANK
YOU SENATOR CENTERED EARLIER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- HER WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE AND DO THIS AND I
THINK I WANNA JUST MAYBE WITH
THE QUESTIONER TO BUILD ON
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS OF MY
TWO COLLEAGUES AND I CHAIR THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
AND WITH THE TRANSITION ON JULY
FIRST. WE HAD HEARINGS BUT WE
HAVE JOINTLY WITH OF THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
BECAUSE AFTER JULY FIRST THAT'S
WHO WOULD HAVE JURISDICTION AND
BEFORE JULY FIRST IF THERE ARE
ANY CHANGES IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE WOULD NEVER SEE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY. AND IT
WAS TRYING TO WORK TOWARDS THAT
AND AT THE TIME WE HAD THOSE
HEARINGS. IT WAS BECOMING A
LITTLE CLEARER WHAT THE NUMBERS
WERE FROM THE PANDEMIC ON DROP
OFF. BECAUSE OF OUR CENTERS NOT
OPERATING. AND WE WERE
CONCERNED PROSPECTIVELY ABOUT
THE TRANSITION ON JULY FIRST
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT AND
SAID THAT VOTES FOR THE
TRANSITION IS GOING PRETTY WELL.
BUT AT THE TIME WE DIDN'T KNOW
FOR SURE. THAT WE WOULD
AUTHORIZE MORE SLOTS AND HIGHER
WAGES SO MY QUESTION IS IN THE
TERMS OF THE TRANSITION AND THE
OTHER THING IS THIS. IS THERE
WAS A LOT OF DEBATE AFTER THE
MAY REVISE ABOUT THE RELATIVE
WEIGHT OF. PRE K. T. K. AND N.
CENTERS AND I TAKE A NOTE THE
SENATE REALLY PUSHED. FOR THE
PARENTS TO HAVE OPTIONS AND FOR
THE OPTIONS TO CONTINUE SO THAT
WHATEVER WORKS BEST WOOD. SO
NOW THAT IS IN ESSENCE WHAT WAS
ADOPTED AND THE ADDITIONAL
MONEY FOR SLOTS AND THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR SALARIES.
SO ARE YOU SAID THE TRANSITIONS
GOING WELL HOW DO YOU THINK
TRANSITIONING TO THIS BIGGER
SYSTEM IS GOING TO GO DO YOU
FEEL A QUICK TO DO IT DO YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE ADEQUATE
TIME LINES. ARE YOU IN THE
PROCESS OF PLANNING AND YOU'RE
NOT SURE YET HOW WOULD YOU
CHARACTERIZE JUST THE CHANGES
THAT ARE ABOUT TO FALL ON YOU
RIGHT NOW. FOUR THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR QUESTION AND I THINK
IT'S A CRITICAL ONE. HAS IT
TOUCHES ON REALLY THE VISION
THAT WE HAVE THAT INVOLVES WHO
CHILD OR FAMILY. AND AS YOU
SEEN WITH THOSE JOINT HEARING.
OF HEALTH AND EDUCATION OUR
FAMILIES LIVE BERKELEY IN BOTH.
RIGHTS BOTH HEALTH AS WELL AS
EDUCATION AND SO WHEN THINKING
ABOUT TIS TRANSITION AND WHAT
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS REALLY AND
MONUMENTUM LOOP FOR THE
LEGISLATOR AND FOR OUR
ADMINISTRATION TO REALLY MAKE.
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES WITHIN THAT WHOLE
CHILD OR FAMILY BISHOP. IT'S
VERY CRITICAL AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BIG STEP. IN TERMS OF
HOW THAT LOOKS LIKE MOVING
FORWARD- I CAN ONLY CALL OUT
THAT. WE HAVE YOU KNOW OUR
VISION IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE. THAT THESE SERVICES SLIP
WITH THEN ALL THE OTHER
SERVICES. AS FAMILIES WALK
THROUGH THE DOORS OF CHAO
PARENTS ABOUT MY PROGRAMS. WE
KNOW THAT TALKING ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS ARCHITECT AT THE
ICEBERG THEY'RE COMING IN WITH
SO MANY OTHER SERVICES PERHAPS
THAT THEY ARE. AWARE THAT THEY
COULD POSSIBLY ACCESS AND
THEREFORE REALLY THINKING
THROUGH HOW THEY- DO THOSE
NAVIGATION. SKILLS AT INCLUDE
LINKING OUR FAMILIES TO OUR
OTHER SAFETY NET PROGRAMS IS
ONE THAT THE- LONG TIME LONG
TERM AND HOPEFULLY COME SOONER.
THAN WHAT WE THINK- TO BE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE WITH THIS MOVE OVER
TO THAT DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. SO WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT WHEN MOVING
FORWARD. THIS WORK IS GOING TO
MAKE AN IMPACT ON THE FAMILIES
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE ENTRY
POINT THAT THEY HAVE WITH THE
SERVICES BUT- A WRAPAROUND.
THAT INCLUDES THE OTHER SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS. THAT FAMILIES
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS. WELL I
REALLY. THAT RESPONSE AND LYFT-THAT THIS GOING TO BE A MOVING
TARGET AS RESPONSIBILITY SHIFTS
AND EXPANSION HAPPENS. AND I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
STAY IN REGULAR TOUCH WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO. MONITOR IT. AND WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO WANT TO BE ABLE
TO BE HELPFUL IF THERE ARE.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES GAPS
ARE OF THE WAYS THAT THIS JUST
WASN'T STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT
REALLY WORKS WE'RE REALLY GOING
TO WANT TO KNOW THAT AND SO FAR
I KNOW THAT WE'LL BE DOING
OVERSIGHT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. BUT I THINK WE WOULD
REALLY HOPE FOR A RELATIONSHIP
GOING FORWARD ON EXACTLY THOSE
ISSUES SO THAT. THAT WE CAN
HELP NAVIGATE THEM ONCE AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE I'M A
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU SENATOR LET ME JUST
DIE I APPRECIATE SO MUCH THE
EXPERTISE OF MY THREE
COLLEAGUES- IN TERMS OF YOUR
HISTORIES YOUR- OVERSIGHT IN
PERSPECTIVE LET ME JUST MAKE
SURE VICE CHAIR WOMAN DID YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU'RE QUESTIONS WERE
ADEQUATELY ANSWERED INCLUDING
THE ONE THAT YOU. SOFT OUT
THERE I THINK SHE RESPONDED IN
PART TO A LOT OF WHAT YOU HAVE
SAID. OKAY DISSENTER I'M JUST
RIGHT I THINK WE'RE ALL VERY
YEAH RIGHT WE'RE ALL VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WE WILL HAVE-
THAT IN IN THE COMMUNITY WE
WILL HAVE THE CHILD CARE
SERVICES THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
TKA THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
MORNING HOURS AND I REMEMBER AS
A WORKING PARENT AND WITH MY
HUSBAND DOWN WHAT DO YOU DO
WHEN THEY GET OUT OF
KINDERGARTEN IN THE EARLY TIME
WHAT'S THERE CAN AFTERNOON VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND I THINK MANY
COMMUNITIES OF ADDRESS THAT.
BUT I THINK IT HAS TO BE
INTEGRATED WITH THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT REALLY IMPORTANT AND
I THINK YOU BROUGHT THAT UP
SENATOR COM LONGER IF THE- YES
SEAMLESS. ABOUT THEY'RE ALL
WORKING TOGETHER. THANK WORKING
AND CERTAINLY WITH- WHAT-
SENATOR LEVIN SAID. CONTINUING
OUR CONVERSATION WITH US IS
GOING TO BE AWFUL VERY
IMPORTANT GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU AND I JUST WANTED TO BE
SURE THIS IS A HUGELY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR SO MANY OF US WE
SPENT LONG HOURS TALKING ABOUT
IT IS RELATED TO. TO BUDGETARY
ISSUES AND TO THE POINT OF YOUR
REFERENCING HOLD WHOLE CHILD
WHOLE FAMILY- THAT SPEAKS TO
ALL THESE THINGS ARE SORT OF
INTEGRATED IN TERMS OF HOW
THAT'S GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
SO I LIKE YOUR VISION I LOOK
FORWARD. TO HOW THIS GETS
IMPLEMENTED AND HAVING THESE
DISCUSSIONS AS OUR- THE CHAIR
OF OUR BUDGET SUB ONE-
REFERENCE SO WE I THANK YOU
AND- REALLY APPRECIATE IT. AND
THE DISCUSSION- I AM GOING TO
NOW MOVES TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND WE WILL START WITH
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND LET'S SEE A
REMINDER ONE LAST REMINDER OF
OUR PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER FOR THE TELECONFERENCE
PORTION OF PUBLIC COMMENT. AND
THAT WOULD BE. 877-226-8189
THAT IS THE NUMBER THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE. AND WITH THAT
WE WILL START IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I DON'T SEE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE AT
THE MOMENT AND I AM GOING TO GO
TO OUR SECOND ROOM THAT IS ROOM
ONE TWELVE. AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE- WAITING TO SPEAK THERE
SO I'M GOING TO WELCOME BACK
OUR MODERATOR MR MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO T. UP PEOPLE.
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
AGAIN I WILL REMIND OUR-
WITNESSES THAT WE NEED YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY
THAT YOU'RE REPRESENTING AND
THEN YOUR POSITION AND SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND WITH
THAT MISTER MODERATOR WELCOME
BACK. THANK YOU SHARE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS APPOINTMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YEAH THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. GO FIRST IN LINE THIRTY
THREE ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN ATKINS A MEMBER MY
NAME IS NICOLE BURKE CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAMS THAT THE ACTUAL. I
RECOGNIZE COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
FINANCIAL AND OUR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WITH ACCESS TO CHILD
CARE AND OTHER NEEDED FAMILY
SUPPORT. IT IS MY PRIVILEGE THE
POCKETBOOK FOR THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR THEY HIGH NEED
MELIHAT. THANK YOU THE DIRECTOR
THE CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL WORK THAT.
I WORK WITH DR HONEY MILLICOM
BUT OVER TWENTY YEARS. I'VE
BEEN IN THE TRENCHES WITH HER
WHEN IN TWENTY TEN POWER PHASE
THREE TRIAL CARE FUNDING WAS
ELIMINATED. AND OVER FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND FIVE O'CLOCK WOULD PUT
IN JEOPARDY. I SAW FIRST HAND
HER ABILITY TO STAY CALM AND
PROVIDES CRITICAL LEADERSHIP
NEEDED TO MANEUVER
UNPRECEDENTED CHAOS WITHIN THE
CHILD CARE YEAH. AS WELL AS THE
VOICE OF SUPPORT FOR FAMILY IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. ACT
IMMEDIATELY THROWN INTO CHAOS.
THE CARE PROGRAMS. BY THEY ARE
THAT. FROM THE CALL DEPARTMENT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF SERVICES.
CAN FREE TRIAL FOR THE WHOLE
FAMILY OKAY. I BELIEVE THAT
HAVING DOCTOR HONEY MILLICOM
SOMEONE WHO WOULD COME FROM THE
FIELD. SOMEONE WHO IS EARNING
THE TRUST OF THE FIELD I FOUND
A CREDIBLE. DURING TIMES OF
ADVERSITY AND HIS ABILITY TO
SUPPORT TOUGH CONVERSATIONS
WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS ARE
FEARFUL OF CHANGE. IS EXACTLY.
THE RIGHT PERSON FOR THIS TIME.
FINALLY DOCTOR NINA. NOT THAT
OF THE THAT BACK AND OTHERS THE
HAVE LET. THE TYPE OF PERSON
WHO OVER THIS THAT WORK INTO.
DELIVER THE DOCTOR. HELLO
STRUCK FOUND AND SHALL. ON
BEHALF OF CAP. ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDREDS OF PARENTS AND
CHILDREN RECORDED BY AGENCIES.%
IN THE CALIFORNIA FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES WE ASK THAT DOCTOR
LEAVE BEHIND EMAIL ON. HER CAR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NEXT WITNESS MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTEEN. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAPPY MUST
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
THE FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION IS
VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR LOOSELY
HIGH MAKE MODEL HANFORD AT THE
HIGH DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT DIVISION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. WHETHER SERVING AS A
COMMISSIONER FOR FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION FOR THE
FRESNO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION FOR PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL OVERSIGHT FOR FIRST
FIVE FRESNO BLIGHT HELPS
PROTECT CHILDREN CHILD
DEVELOPMENT CENTER DR HEINE
MAIL FILE HIM HAS ALWAYS
pOCCASIONALLY CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES HE
HAS MAINTAINED A STEADY COURSE
TOWARDS ENSURING EVERY CHILD
RECEIVES THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND IN
LIFE. MOVING HAS OFTEN TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
SHURI AKI PLAYED FROM THE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT IT IS THE SAME
CURIOSITY BUT IT'S MADE HER AN
AVID AND WILLING LISTENER
ADVOCATE PARTNER AND STRATEGIST
WHO PRIORITIZES THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES TO GUIDE THE IMPORTANT
DECISIONS THAT SHE HAS BEEN
ASKED TO MAKE WE KNOW THAT IN
HER NEW ROLE AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SHE WILL USE HER OWN THEIR
DICKS VARIANCES TO CHAMPION THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS YOUNG
CHILDREN. FOR THESE REASONS THE
FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT. HER
CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. LINE THIRTY. THANK YOU
CANNOT AND GETTING HERE ON THE
AND YEAH YOU TELL WE SUPPORT
THE NOT OF DR NEW HIGHMANHATTAN TWO BB THAT HE
KNOCKED ON HELP AND- AT THE
CALIFORNIA'S OF SOCIAL. DOT
HONEY MELON HAD THE X. IN THE
TOP WORLD GEN WORKING UNDER
AREAS AND DINNER HOW CARE
DESERT AND HAVE YOU BIRTH AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF CHILD CARE
EARLY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO
THEIR COMMUNITY WE HAVE WORKED
ALONG SIDE- DOCTOR HAINAN
ISLAND I'M ON THAT EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COMMISSION AND
THROUGH OUR CHILDCARE UNION ETP
YOU SEE AND THEN I THINK THAT
ALL AND CONSIDERING IT AS WELL
AND VERY UNDERSTANDING AND I
NEED YOUR SUPPORT I WORK FOR A
LONG TIME THE CHILDREN. AND
FAMILIES THAT WE SUPPORT
APPOINTMENT AND- WE HAVE TO PUT
APPOINTMENT RULES COMMITTEE
CONFERENCE. AND MARKETING
DIRECTOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WEEK. WELL I.
THIRTY TWO. I CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY MY NAME
IS. I SUPPORT MY GOD MATTER
SLASH NINA MARIA GUADALUPE BANK
FINANCE NOT HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM SO
PLEASED YOU TOOK TIME TO CALL
IN AND- TAKE AND PARTICIPATE IN
YOUR DEMOCRATIC OPPORTUNITIES
IN GOVERNMENT. SORRY MR
MODERATOR PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD.
METROLINE. TWENTY TWO. AFTER A
NEW MANAGER AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS RATES ARE ACCOUNT HE WAS
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE APPOINTMENT OF DR MARIA
GUADALUPE I MEAN MY- AND I
THINK. HE HAS WORKED CLOSELY
DOCTOR BROWN IN THE PAST. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER IN HER NEW OLD DEPUTY
DIRECTOR TO SUPPORT THE CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO SAY THE
YOUNG PERSON IS A HARD ACT TO
FOLLOW. BUT AT MISTER MODERATOR
GO RIGHT AHEAD. I AM. TWENTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON- MADAM
CHAIR I ALSO WITH WILL THAT
NEVER THOUGHT I'D BE RIGHT
AFTER- HEARD THAT BOCKENHEIM
NEEDS SO I'M GLAD THERE WAS A
DOCTOR IN BETWEEN. OKAY
AFTERNOON TO OF THE- MY NAME IS
JACKIE. WONG I AM THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR BIRTH FIVE
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE SO PROUD
AND EXCITED TO SUPPORT I CAN DO
THINGS ON A MAN HIGH AND
APPOINTED. BY THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ALL CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT NOT WITH IT AND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT. OF
ABOUT HEINONEN'S A LEADER IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
A TRUCK AND I'M FOR AGENCIES
ARE NOT. THAT WORK WITH. AND
FOR CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
FAMILIES. MATTER EXPERTISE THE
FIELD OF EDUCATION COUPLED WITH
OUR LEADERSHIP ON THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD POLICY COUNCIL. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR THE
EDUCATION OF YOUNG CHILDREN AND
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
PROGRAM TO MENTOR
ADMINISTRATORS- CAL THE NON
DEVELOPMENT. MAKE HER A
TREMENDOUS. BUT IT OF
CALIFORNIA AND- WE HAVEN'T SO
FORTUNATE WELCOME BACK THE
CLOCK ARE NO HAN AND CAN I TALK
TO HER ABOUT LEADERS AS A
COMMISSIONER AND THE CHAIR OF
THE- WE HAVE WITNESSED HOUSE
EXPERTISE PERMANENT GENUINE FOR
CAL. AFTER HIGH MENTAL A BLACK
IN. RANGING FROM LOW TO. WHICH
B. VAL WILL BE ACTUALLY YEAH IN
THEIR AND THEN CHILD CARE
LITTLE FOR ALL THESE REASONS
AND SO MANY MORE WE. STRONGLY
AND RESPECTFUL. FROM SUPPORTERS
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS OF
COURSE TO HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. SO WILL AGAIN
STARTING ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. I SEE NO ONE APPROACHING
THE PODIUM WILL LOOK AGAIN AT
ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO ONE HAS
ENTERED THAT ROOM SO MISTER
MODERATOR I'M GOING TO COME
BACK TO YOU FOR WITNESSES WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS APPOINTMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO LINES IN Q. MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR HELP AND ASSISTANCE TODAY
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE IT- SO
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM WITNESSES I'M GOING
TO BRING IT BACK INTO. THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
EMOTION. I WOULD MOVE THE
CONFIRMATION CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THAT
MOTION MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROVE
KAMLAGER HI I'M LONGER I
LAYERED HI I FAITH ALL RIGHT
AYE ATKINS I CAN FIVE FOUR TO
ZERO THANK YOU THAT WAS FOUR
ZERO YOUR CONFIRMATION WILL
MOVE TO THE SENATE FLOOR AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND YOUR SERVICE TO OUR STATE
CONGRATULATIONS. OKAY THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA AND SO I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY AND PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR YOU CAN VISIT OUR WEBSITE
FOR INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND SO WE WANT
TO INCLUDE THAT TESTIMONY IN
OUR OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COOPERATION TODAY ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL NOW
MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.